all right but what's most important is
this final one okay it's neither
or my recommendation or rather it's both
of our recommendations it's both
this one we we were never going to do a
dojin episode
without talking about metamorphosis one
of the most legendary dojins out there
okay connor's never read it before okay
before you start i got something to say
i have a confession to make guys go on
oh no what are you gonna say gone
[__] i have before this never read
metamorphosis really
yes wow metamorphosis has been
my full metal alchemist
[Music]
was an episode of making journey
congratulations hey i i just need it it
takes 10 [__] minutes to read it's
not
it's not 10 500 it's like a 20 20 30
minute yeah yeah but like
it was it was the one where i'm just
like people have talked about it so much
that i had just been putting it off yeah
so it was that one hentai when i'm just
like
i will read metamorphosis when i am
ready to read metamorphosis i will say
for all i've heard about this i almost
expected it to be more [__] up than it
was
did you feel that way it was pretty
[__] up okay but because of the
reputation it had
i expected it to be you overhyped
yourself i thought it was gonna be even
worse than it was
so did you just hype up the [__] up
nurse in your head well you know i mean
i've been an anime fan for a long time
you hear about this yeah
constantly it's referenced constantly as
being that one [__] up thing
yeah you know and it's [__] up for a
vanilla audience yeah
i i've watched the final season of game
of thrones i know true disappointment
and that's this is kind of what it felt
like a little bit i was like this is
[__] don't get me wrong it's very [__]
up it is [__] well
i almost expected something worse like i
almost expected like
absolutely well i think i think it's
because you've already put your foot
in the dojin and like hentai yeah i mean
i i know this is like i know this is
like
grade a [__] up of someone who's like
never stepped foot into that right i
feel like i've seen estee are [__] up
and this is 80 are [__] up like it's
very [__] up and very uncomfortable
maybe it's just more accessible i'm not
really sure why this one has gotten a
notoriety
i think it's because this was one of i
think this was just that one
dojin that really just got around i
guess for
whatever reason it is and i'm like oh
should we explain the promise
yeah yeah metamorphosis why don't you
very very well known
uh dojin yes about a girl
who you know she doesn't she's not the
prettiest girl out there and then she
gets a makeover
and then suddenly literally takes off
her glasses
takes off her glasses puts on a bit of
makeup becomes hot
because i'm hot and then guys you you
have seen this beginning panel somewhere
if you're in the anime community you've
seen this somewhere it's iconic it's
funny
even i know what this piece yeah yeah
yeah and then i didn't i didn't know any
of the other panel which is this is the
before and this is the after yeah
yeah completely different character yeah
and then this character is just shocked
that guys are now paying attention to
her
and that they want to [__] her and so
she starts [__] these guys and it
gets really derailed
really fast uh yeah it's a big yikes of
a read
i mean i mean how do i explain it i mean
his okay
let me let me let me let me just uh i i
put some notes down
seems normal so far uh not fond
of how his dad reacted to her makeup
of her dad reacted to her makeup yeah
what scene was that makeover makeover
oh yeah she's a chapter three
so she gets a makeover and the father's
like oh okay
i was like you won't believe what
happens next i was like i was like
i do not like that i do not like that
look he gave me this does not mean good
things
and unfortunately i was correct top 10
foreshadowing mothers
literally watch mojo you can take this
from the top 10 short foreshadowing
moments in anime uh
yeah so you know a kind of sleazy dude
kind of uses her for sex
you know and then gives you drugs yeah i
think i think the biggest
aspect of the story which i've never
seen in any other dojinshi before
was the drug angle right yeah it was
pretty uncomfortable
yeah yeah it was pretty uncomfortable
yeah where way was like he
this so she puts on makeup she has her
makeover
and then she finds this douchebag guy
who basically gives her a drug
who and she and she's like kind of like
a mandy ripoff kind of thing yeah yeah
yeah and basically she
experiences the best sex of all just one
of the best experiences of her life
literally the first time she she's a
virgin then and she just becomes kind of
a nymphomaniac
right where she just and a drug addict
yeah well a sex and a drug addict
at this point right where she's addicted
to the sex and she's addicted to the
drugs
and she's addicted to the sex and drugs
and then
this it just kind of spirals down from
there it is it is
it is like it is a downward curve from
like chapter one
you know but you almost feel like when
it's when it's
when the character is like this
disconnected and like barely gives you
any
um signs of wanting to i don't know like
this
it feels so forced at times this this
this decline
of mental state where it's like all
right all right you're just doing the
[__] best of depression hits at this
point or something
like literally you're just trying to get
i feel like they're just making things
bad for the sake of it like there's
like a lot of the time i was like i
guess yeah
like there was a moment in it where i
was like i don't know extra doubt on
that one
where like which point which point so it
was in the school yeah where
during the story um they know that she
went to a hotel
okay so okay i suppose i should back up
so she has this boyfriend
uh you know who's kind of a scumbag
gives her drugs yeah and then she kind
of wants money
so she starts [__] an old guy who
gives her money a little disturbing and
the sexy
ugly blast attack literally really it's
not an uncomfortable it's it's quite
uncomfortable what am i saying it's very
uncomfortable
i don't mean to say not uncomfortable
it's very uncomfortable um and then
for some reason one of the students
finds out that she went to this place
so naturally all of the boys together
decide well let's all get [__] from
her
that's that's that's what me and the
boys do at school
of course first of all never gonna
happen
but also that was the part where i was
like i feel like this is kind of
like ah just a little extra like that
was where i was like i get it it's very
depressing but i was like yeah this
feels really forced this part
i'm like you're making the shad for the
sake of it do you agree with that whole
school part
i'm like this is a bit of a stretch i
mean this it's just like a a trope that
i've seen in so many times and they all
start [__] here and i'm like
name one school kid that minds showing
his dick to anyone let alone [__]
someone in front of his friend
you'd be surprised in japan i i don't i
don't know man i i don't know
i mean this is a culture that is grown
up
on just seeing each other's dicks in the
onset right that's like
it is just probably another day in the
office the same
i feel like they're just doing this i
mean you say it's a stress but again
it's like such a trope that you've seen
dojo yeah
yeah yeah yeah it happens all the time
it's not even like surprising yeah but i
guess when it's used in a way it's like
feel sorry for this girl feel
like sadness i'm like no i mean i mean
that wasn't even the part where i felt
sadness at all like it was it was hard
it was after that
like yeah what i would say is this is
like the requiem for a dream of hentai
and i didn't think i would say that in
like a sentence
but it's a thing it is it is a thing
this is so after
after she sleeps with this old guy for
money after she gets blackmailed by the
other kids in a school to have sex with
them and do all this
yeah which is really horrifying it's not
portrayed very well yeah like it's
portrayed very
horrifyingly um her dad wants a piece of
the action and this is where i'm like
for [__] sake
it's just like this is like literally
the the saying my day can't get any
worse
it's literally here this is literally oh
my god what i even say about this thing
this is so
[__] up that i'm like oh my god like
yeah what why and then she [__] the the
dad [__] her
right and it goes on and the mum blames
her and i'm like
really really like
you were married to this man for how
long and you think it's your daughter's
fault
come on come the [__] on no way
i bet 99 of men uh uh wives should be
like
man you're out i don't care what
happened i don't care who tempted who
you're [__] out yeah you're the
problem
you should [__] know better yeah i'm
like that's where i was like
all right okay okay maybe maybe i'm like
maybe i'll see where this goes yeah yeah
i don't know about this move chief
i don't know could you see a world where
the mum would be like i blame your
daughter for [__] that
i mean [__] i don't know man
i don't know anyone who's been in that
[Music]
situation
this is just [__] weird this one was
[__] weird uncomfortable
i'm like i get why it's got a reputation
but i was just like
oh no it is absolutely [__] up and
it's not supposed it's it's one of those
versions where it's
not supposed to be enjoyed in the
conventional way of enjoying a donation
you know sometimes i'm i'm a [__] i'm
a [__] of course yes
i'm a [__] say i think this doesn't
masterpiece thank you
thank you
i raised this boy this is like i google
every depressing thing that could happen
in life
i put it in a doujin i am how is that a
masterpiece i have
never been so engrossed in a doujin
before
like i where where like i was turning
every page i know
i know i was just like i was like
because i was thinking
where is this chatting where is this
dozen gonna go next
i i'm 100 serious when i'm just like i
literally saw it from like
the moment she met this guy i'm like i
bet just [__] up after [__] up [__]
is gonna
the moment she gave him drug uh he gave
her drugs i'm like i know this is going
this is just gonna it has the greatest
shown in battle of all time dude who is
going to win
one innocent girl or one spiky boy
no because like like i tried to come i
like i feel like
you came in with like a lot of
preconceived notions where you're just
like this is [__] up i'm ready for
this where
if if this was a movie or a tv show or
anything
this would be like just like bait here
of like this is just basic like this is
just so
lazy in terms of how how little they try
to sell this is like a realistic journey
that i'm like you know we've we've had
movies about stuff like this that are
[__] up
that have done this so much better that
i'm like literally requiem for a dream
like yeah
just because this is in dojin format and
it's literally the only one that's like
how about we be depressing
you know it's like i don't want to give
it props for that because i i give it
props for that
i think it's a bit more than that yeah
but i think it's a little maybe i'm
being a little too harsh but i feel like
this has been done before in other
places
because because i i feel like metaphor
metamorphosis has
like well now has to battle with it
being like the meme
doujin right because it's it's not it's
like people don't judge it on its own
merit anymore people judge it being like
haha i've seen this been memed
everywhere as like the big thing that
people
like recommend to people to like [__]
them up and stuff like that and it's
like
one one thing one thing that's like i
don't like is that
people in in like the hentai community
or what i've seen people are just like
i've seen more [__] up [__] than this
i've seen worse things than this and i'm
just like of course you have
i too watch euphoria i do have seen some
of the [__] that city is recommended and
[__] reviewed
like i've seen the [__] collection of
you know i i you know i did go in you
know a part of me obviously went into
this thing
it's gonna be the most [__] up thing
i've ever seen in my life because
everyone's recommending it but you know
it wasn't that
then the other hand i'm like you know
it's almost trying too hard
to to make me feel sadness
for this character that i don't really
feel like they built her up
that well like honestly personally i
thought they built her up really well
it was so short and sweet and it's like
i guess
it felt very one-dimensional to me i
felt like there wasn't enough depth to
the character
and then the moment [__] started going
wrong look at us that was up to the
character
listen listen if you want to get out if
you want
if you want me to give a [__] about this
story you sit here say it's a
masterpiece
i'm a hit i'ma sit back and be like
listen i'll find i'll talk about the
characters for one goddamn minute
okay the moment [__] started going wrong
for her all character development went
out the [__] window there was like
nothing was
added or introduced it was like all
right it's like the it's like an apple
event it's like
we've seen the iphone we've seen being
taken advantage of
let me introduce being taken advantage
of by your father and i was like
that's what i felt like i felt like i
was being condescended to in terms of
the [__] that was coming up